we start getting towards the end of this
deployment
and obviously
mark got killed on august 2nd
and and then
september 29th
um mikey gets killed
yeah and we're i mean we're
we're not we're not done operating by
any stretch because we did a bunch more
operations but it was definitely winding
down at that point
yeah we had to start thinking about
redeployment
yeah and uh
i mean we're all packed up i remember
because we weren't out at uh
out of cricket or anymore yeah we had
the guys that were you were one of the
guys that had come back from corregidor
as we started trying to
filter guys back consolidation i was so
mad i had to come back
you know i think about every day when i
feel this finger because i i
you know i cut my finger down to the
bone and uh they actually had to cast
back me out
uh to go get surgery on my finger
because i thought i was going to lose it
because
we tried to work on it across the street
at the aids station which those guys are
phenomenal combat medics over there
and when they were like dude we need a
bird for you you're going to lose your
finger
um delta platoon commander and the
badger were like
dude we have yeah absolutely you know so
i went back grabbed some gear
and um you know i feel that every day
just hard um like that was the only op i
wasn't on
you know and every time we went out i
always said a group prayer for the guys
it didn't matter if it was like hey we
have to go right now delta platoon
commander or the badger or someone would
be like hey
we got to get jp real quick and i'd say
group prayer and we'd roll and that was
the only one
that i wasn't a part of and uh you know
mikey was my a dub gunner you know he
was
always next to me when i was doing my
sniper over watches and
he was next to me when i was rocking
point you know because you needed a dub
gunner
and jp might have gotten a little crazy
towards the last half of the deployment
and started walking point with the 300
win mag
and mikey was there and i wasn't there
you know
and
i don't know so
well the good news is you got to go home
with him yes
yeah gotta escort his body home
which was
unlike anything else you know you're
like cool
you know you get to be a part of that
but also at the same time you're like
this is really shitty to be a part of
you know what i mean like i don't know
it's like
yeah i wanted to be there and make sure
everything went well and i just
remember us flying back and just
just just staring at the flag over his
coffin you know
and some guys would you know lay next to
the casket and we'd
lean up against it
yeah it was just getting to bring him
home was important
to be a part of that but uh
you know everybody felt so much guilt
and uh we all we all try to keep each
other accountable on that you know it's
like hey man this is war
you know mikey saved a lot of lives
you know and we made an impact over
there
and so it wasn't like it was for nothing
and
what he did i mean the guys lives that
he saved
they all now have families and kids
you know a couple of them had kids mikey
had the easy out
and just like he always did he never
took
the easy road he took the harder road
the road that would
actually make a difference and this time
was alive those
of those guys around him and
it was just the ride back i mean you
just thinking about all that and
you know it was also kind of a blur as
well you know like i remember
you know just like just rubbing the flag
you know
the flag's always been very important to
me i remember graduating how awake and
just seeing the
flag fly and then you hear the national
anthem
and just seeing it over one of your boys
caskets was
just brought a new level of connection
and love
for that amazing flag that we have
and i just remember i just sat there and
i just
would just rub the flag just rub it you
know because i had flags that i carried
with me on every deployment every
mission
i still do that sometimes like my wife
amanda will just
i'll be doing something and i'll find a
flag and i'll just i just kind of rub it
and she's like she knows you know she's
like that's like my little trigger you
know i'm just
my trigger point i'm just i started
thinking about things again
and you know i've taught my kids
aiden cora and nola
to love and respect the flag like
whenever they see a flag they're like
daddy daddy it's your favorite thing
daddy it's daddy's favorite thing you
know they love getting american flag
t-shirts
and shorts uh they saw some american
cowboy boots of course my daughters want
those now
and i've been honest with my kids you
know
my boy aiden i call my bonus boy he's my
step-son i love him just like mine
you know he he asked me about the flag
and why is it so important to me and i
told him i'm like you know
it was it's been draped over a lot of
caskets of my buddies that
didn't make at home that were killed
overseas he's such a special kid he was
just like
that makes sense and you know and he
just
he sees a flag and i explained to him
why a flag's at half mass
and he's even said hey i'm sorry that
flag's at half mass
like he doesn't know why but he knows
something happened and he knows what it
does to me and
guys like you or the flag's at half-mast
something
horrible has happened and he knows that
you know and so
i just remember
you know we i think he went to bed
bethesda
and then we continued on to san diego
and um just tried to mentally reset for
a couple days you know you're back in
san diego
it's awesome but it just didn't it
yeah it had nothing you know because you
knew you're waiting to receive your
one of your boys bodies you know
so it didn't matter where we were it
didn't matter we're in san diego
like we didn't want to be in san diego
we want to be
back overseas still you know
when
when we went to
habane to put him on the bird
and
casket was open yeah and we were just
filing by
you know and i remember
you were ahead of me we were walking
into like a mill van
yeah it wasn't it wasn't like a one-way
thing it's a cold no van
it's a cold mill van and
you were ahead of me you know you were
one you were just you're literally right
ahead of me
and you walked in and you know you
you you know you took your last look at
mike and
you put your hand on the on the casket
and you turned around and i was right
you know we were just looking at each
other
and
when i saw your face the look in your
face
i was
i felt super worried
because i could tell that you were tore
up
and i said to myself hey man
jocko you need to get your [__] game
together right now
and be strong
and you were and that's what we needed
and
guys like the delta platoon commander
super super strong for us but you saw
them hurt i mean everybody's hurting you
know it was
you know that deployment you can't not
be close with somebody you know
especially someone like mikey man like
he he knows i like my sleep
and so he would make sure i didn't get
my sleep just because mikey didn't sleep
and we were we you know we're our rooms
right next to each other you know i was
back in this corner he's over in this
other corner and there's a
sheet of plywood between the two of us
and
you know he was always like what's up
holmes he's like hey holmes you sleeping
i'm like
yeah i'm trying to holmes
he's like he's like cool and he'd open
up the tarp
you know the little cammy you know tarp
that i had over
for my door and just come in and sit on
the edge of the bed i'm like
what's up buddy he's like nothing just
want you know you just talk about family
stuff
and you could tell a lot was on his mind
you know
and uh he's like hey you want to watch
the newest episode of thirsty traveler
my parents sent me the thirsty traveler
i was like no but i'm awake so i guess
we're going to watch the thirsty
traveler
because there's a couple times where i'd
be like hey bro like i'm trying to sleep
like just go do your own thing you know
what i mean
and he had a little hole that he carved
into the plywood between our rooms
and he would crack kim lights and push
them
through and they'd fall right next to
where i was sleeping and i'm like
i'm going to strangle this guy but it
was my boy mikey you know
like he was my boy um you know we're
real close in the workup
and then obviously deployment you know
we should ride three bikes together and
anyway so deployment he was just fun it
was just i say all it says is he did
that with everybody
yeah it was hard not to be close to him
it was uh
you know there's a different connection
when you're at when you're legitimately
at
in war with your boys you know that's
why all the army and marine guys that we
served with
like anytime i see i still see some of
them once in a while i randomly ran into
one of them up in ohio
and i was just like dude and i just i
was up there on a sales trip and i just
ditched my sales team guys
you know because i wanted to hang out
with them you know i just and there's
been other trips where
i same thing another one my boy nick
cobbs you know ran into him i was with
my sales team and
it's like come on you know it's just
that connection is just it's hard to
explain i mean you guys know how it is
doing jiu jitsu in combat sports where
you're rolling with guys and you
you legitimately you're helping guys cut
weight and just all this stuff like
there's that bond in that connection
take that
times it by a thousand and then add some
more and that's the connection you get
with these boys in combat so
it it's real hard i mean and part of it
is
that's just who i am like i wear my
heart on my sleeve
i i just connect and attach to people
very closely and
you know mikey is just it was it was it
was really hard and
and that's the look that i saw on your
face that's the look that i saw on your
face
i was like and i know i mean obviously i
know what kind of personality you have i
knew what kind of personality you have
and i saw that look of devastation and
it was the first time because we'd been
together i mean we we were
we heard the news we you know but it was
the first time that i saw your your look
where it was almost like that was the
first time that you really realized
that mikey was gone that was it yeah
maybe i'm right or wrong
but from the look in your face i was
like okay
he he is he is devastated right now
and and that's what i thought to myself
and again i mean
i i don't i saw you as my little brother
mean for sure i don't mean that in
any kind of derogatory way in any sense
but i literally saw you as like my blood
little brother yeah
and so to see you just devastated like
that
and i knew that you were looking at me
like well okay what's jocko going to do
and i knew that i knew what i had to do
yeah was i had to show like
listen this is what we do this is who we
are
get your [__] together jocko and and
handle this
and not saying i didn't you know i'm not
saying i was a uh a robot
yeah but i knew that i had to maintain
strength you have to and find that so
that you guys could go
all right we're gonna be okay what have
we
what's been pounded into our minds since
buds win the fight like
if you're in a fight win the fight win
the firefight right and right then that
our fight was you had to keep the guys
together you know that's why i thought
it was
self-aid buddy aid right you get shot
you get hurt you take care of yourselves
because if you're in a firefight your
boys are going to win the fire fight
first before they can take care of you
that's just part of it that's how we
operate
and you had to do that yeah
no doubt i mean that you're in that
highest leadership position
like yeah you just and the same thing
like i had to get myself together you
know just because
other guys in the platoon like i thought
or at least i felt like they looked up
to me as well
and you know especially after deployment
you know i just you had to keep your
stuff together you know and
it was just it's just a weird weird you
know i don't know the first time i ever
experienced that
you know at that level so